ما موقف اطراف الصراع في السودان من خروج
رموز نظام البشير من السجن
الجيش السوداني سلطه اداره السجون خارج
نطاق اختصاصنا وتحت مسؤوليه وزاره
الداخليه
الدعم السريع لا سيطره لدينا على السجون
في السودان وهذه مسؤوليه الشرطه
الميليشيات المتمرده اجبرت شرطه السجون
على اطلاق سراح النزلاء قيادات المواليه
للبشير في الجيش هي المسؤوله عن اطلاق
سراحه
اداره سجن كوبر اطلقت سراح نزلائه بسبب
انقطاع المياه والكهرباء والاعاشه خروج
قيادات البشير من سجن كوبر صدمه وانتكاسه
للشعب السوداني نحن غير معنيين باي بيانات
من اي جماعه او افراد خرجوا من السجون
مغادره قيادات النظام البشير للسجن امر
متوقع وبعضهم يطلبون دوليا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات